我不是特別喜歡去講很多伊朗的事情
但是最近的市場基本上都是Geo political driven
所以我覺得還是不得不去講它
然後我把這也放在前面
然後其實上週還是有挺多其他可以關注的事情
包括GTC
然後包括那個美聯儲的會議
然後和美聯儲後續會做什麼事情
但是現在市場我就形容一下現在市場的狀態
我感覺現在市場其實更加像一個船在開
然後這個船雖然我們開船是要看著這個風向的
但是現在創和就是戰爭或者是美國的這個政策
其實是一個更加強的發動機
它可以逆著風來開
像星期一的時候
其實我中間有很多內容是在周末準備的
所以在星期一的時候有特朗普
川普說到關於伊朗
然後說跟伊朗進行談判
然後
市場當然了很快就反
風險市場很快就反彈了
包括有價最多的時候可能跌了10%吧
然後
我覺得這些都是一些
因為現在市場我覺得兩邊都非常難做
就是
因為它有政策的很大的影響性
然後從事的話呢那個市場也有position
然後加上其實戰爭還在持續
所以我覺得
本質上
最終就我先說一下我對於這個星期一的這個新聞的一個看法
我覺得只要油還沒有過滑那麼多海峽還沒有大量的過著海峽
你想
正常的情況下應該要走20個米臉一天吧
只要它沒有過去就是會有很多的變數
然後是不是說現在因為有傳言是這麼講的就是美國其實和中國談得不錯
然後在中國的主導下面然後讓那個伊朗跟美國就是在這個事情上平息
但我覺得吧伊朗現在的政府處於一個混亂的狀態
從它的埃亞托勒從他那個哈密內伊被炸死了以後
新的埃亞托勒是irgc扶植上去的他內部的
而且跟他一起被炸死有40個人
然後後面還陸陸續續有很多的人被炸死然後
我是感覺
在伊朗的統治內部現在處於機器風化的狀態
根據原來最高領袖的指示在作戰然後下層的軍官很希望他領導被炸死
所以也有可能會做出一些更加過激的行為
然後導致報復讓他領導被炸死自己可以上去
所以整個我覺得伊朗的局勢並沒有那麼清晰
至少並不像星期一市場交易的時候怎麼清晰
就覺得好像美國和以色列馬上會跟伊朗合談了
然後這個事情要解決
那我也不清楚最後結果會怎麼樣
但本質上中間的變數還是很大的
那麼我們今天其實我覺得從兩個角度
從伊朗的危機從兩個角度來講
就是我們在真正發生危機的時候
Wars Case會在哪裡
包括我們上週再上週都講過這個問題
我們現在市場有沒有完全pricing就定價了
可能會發生Wars Case
然後這是一個
然後第二個就是如果沒有正常情況
我們認為是3月份4月份
甚至4月份
4月份這個危機有可能會解除
那麼在解除的情況下
市場會大概在哪裡
我這個怎麼往下翻
翻不了
然後可以往下翻
OK
就市場如果危機解除的話
然後會到哪裡去
然後我們再去講一下美聯儲
或者是因為這個
因為這個已經是會改變我們PCE
會改變我們通漲
會改變我們經濟存長的一個核心變量
所以在這個核心變量討論完以後
根據不同的情況
然後我們來說一下
接下去聯儲可能會怎麼動
然後我們在風險市場上的操作
比如說現在市場的估值
我覺得已經到底了
在美國的市場估值
中國沒有
中國還是比較高
但美國市場估值已經到底
然後大很多的公司的估值
和去年4月份
底部最最底的那個位置差不多
那麼但是面臨這樣的一個
石油危機
我們如果超底
應該是怎麼去怎麼去投資
怎麼去做
然後我覺得這幾個問題
然後市場上
我覺得就這個根據GS的高深的
一個預測
就是說本質上是
我們上上周講到一個入
10%的預游價上升
導致0.04%的PCE的上升
導致0.1%的GDP的下降
所以它的影響有更像
像跟關稅有點像
或者說更加嚴重
然後我們之前的
就是cover page上面
這一張圖其實已經說明了
就是這一次的石油危機
比73年比90年都要嚴重
就如果它能夠延續很長時間
上周沒有提到
就是說我們早看油價上升百分之十
油價上升百分之十要加權平均
就是說我們到年底
就只有時間
weight average 時間的油價
如果是上升百分之十
所以並不說我現在shock找到150
這個找到150就做數
就會影響這樣
但是更多的是說
我持續多長的時間
然後我持續下去會怎麼樣
那麼簡單的來說的話
而且另外一個
就是油價也不是我今天
假設我明天
然後讓所有的傳送
或怎麽還採下通過
然後conflate結束
油價就馬上回到之前的價位
因為油本身是一個供需極其
inelastic 就是什麽說
就是供需極其沒有彈性的東西
一旦需求面開始
就是需求面被迫的開始減少
所以油價就會飆升
然後一旦供應面減少
時候就是你需要放出存量
然後持續的去把你減少
要的供應然後給補上的
我們現在減少供應已經不少了
因為已經打了十幾天了
打20多天了
對吧
20天
然後但是我們放了
這個SPR和IEA放了
大概4億同優
然後這些油
其實是需要120天時間
來平衡我們預測到4月初
能夠把這個通話的問題解決
那麽這個供需是能夠平衡的
不代表著IEA和SPR
能夠重新把這個油的儲量建立錢
因為儲量建立錢要重新買油
這個是一個沒有什麽彈性的市場
你是會把油價推上去
所以消化這一部分
這個我們叫supply shock
就是供應衝擊
是需要時間來消化的
並不是馬上能夠解決的
那如果說油的危機
就像高聲的basic case
高聲的upside case
走到更長的時間
比方說我們2、3個月
那麽它對於通脹的影響
和特別是我覺得比較嚴重
是對於GDP的影響
是會後面體現
而且對於GDP的影響
我們在這個預期
高聲的這個上面PPD預期
可能稍微是上一次的
高聲的預期可能在basic case 2.3
然後就是降0.2%到0.3%的GDP增長
就是現在這個叫做damage is done
已經發生了
這個危機已經發生了
也就是哪怕我今天停掉
我對於年底的增長
還是會有這個影響
對於年底的通脹
相對來說影響沒有很大
因為你要傳導到通脹
傳導到pce
其實是主要是通過旅行
通過油價這些東西傳導
現在pc上我們叫service
就是服務類的
就是工資直接的傳導
效果沒有那麽明顯
但是對於增長影響更加直接
但是在extreme case
就是我們認為它到6月份以後
或者是更長時間
extreme case現在只是說到6個月以後
沒有說比方說持續6個月
這麽危險
到6個月以後
那加權平均的油價就要到150以上
因為把你能夠釋放
就我們現在美國
包括IEA在做準備油價的釋放
都是針對4月中要把這個事情解決
4月初要把這個事情解決
那如果是維持真的很長時間
比方說幾個月的話
油價是完全沒有做好這個準備的
那麽沒有做好這個準備
開了PCE可能會到5%以上
然後核心PCE又到3%
然後美國會Recession
這個是一個非常非常嚴重的事情
也就是
也就是我們現在完全在資本市場
沒有pricing的這樣的一個情況
這個情況會不會發生呢
很有可能不會
別問星期一
就是說星期一的時候
川普這個態度出來
我覺得不一定會
但是
即使不會也有可能會在某個時點交易到
就是畢竟現在沒有開放食藥
所以
這個風險是不是存在
即使我覺得在星期一川普
對那個說我跟伊朗談得很好以後
我覺得這個風險還是存在
因為戰爭
就我們在三個星期前想到戰爭
我覺得就是戰爭並不是一個party
做解鎖就解鎖的
不是中國和美國兩邊握好手
大哥去說我去調停
就能夠調停好
這個原因我剛才已經講了
就因伊朗內部現在我覺得是很混亂
並不是一個人能夠說
我把這個事情解決
很多party
他兒子應該現在已經重上了
新的兒子可能已經重上了
很多party
很多那個勢力
都想在這個過程中間奪權
獲得更大的權力
獲得更大的權力就要去反美
要么就反美
讓自己領導被炸死
把跟美國綏靖派給高層
所以這個政治的playbook
我覺得經歷過很多鬥爭的
我們其實回頭看幾年歷史
都按說能想
所以能不能馬上達成和平協議
我覺得比較疑惑的
市場現在在兩個方向上
沒有capitulate
沒有投降
第一個就是伊朗
伊朗的事情
沒有經歷一個投降的過程
但是我們再說利率之前
其實我可以先提一下
市場的倉位相對來說
現在已經是偏向於空艙
就是空艙的壓力比較大
就空艙就已經是偏空走得比較遠了
就是你如果把它當成
拉弓射箭的話
它已經快拉到幾千
拉得比較緊
但是確實那個對伊朗的事情
現在並沒有一個投降的過程
我覺得沒有投降是今年的主旋律
現在就伊朗市場沒有投降
同時的話
對於token的需求
對AI的需求上也沒有投降
這個待會我們會再講到
GTC的時候會提到
就是雖然英偉達在GTC的時候
說天開心的事情
英偉達在GTC的時候
給出了一個三年的藍圖
就大概是三年吧
就是三年不到
然後兩年多
給出了一個藍圖
一萬億的收入
然後帶動了所有它的貢獲商
其實情緒都很高
但是市場本質上
對英偉達還沒有買單
為什麼呢
因為你有一萬億的需求
那你的CAPEX
就是他覺得總是要把英偉達
跟CAPEX連在一起
這個事情我就不重複了
我們上周也說過
我覺得不是
不是那麼直接連接的
就是CAPEX既是
CAPEX增長變化
英偉達的業績
Novellion的業績和他的收入
不單會變化
但是總是要把他跟未來的
CAPEX連在一起
然後其實市場更想看到的是
後面的需求段
有沒有增長出來
那這個我覺得
在今年晚一點的時候
市場會Compatulate
不會投降
因為我這個BBT就是
Glock
我這個BBT就是
就是Andopic線
所以現在
會在越來越多的不同的環境裡面
就會看到
就是他的這個各方面的應用越來越多
包括頭肯的需求
指數性的需求
這個是不太會經商
所以市場會這麼好Compatulate
但是
這個還沒有Compatulate
我覺得兩個沒有投降
是現場市場主權率
但是比較危險的是有可能
對於伊朗的事情
大概會先投降
先投降就有可能會出現問題
所以
但這個很有很大程度上
是有那個
政治的play在裡面
我在星期一
川普已經明確的講了
我跟伊朗人談了很好的時候
我表示一個問得好
他傳下來沒過
沒有過就是一個問得好
當然如果你們對
有人對於這個和平的情況
就是比較非常看好的話
那我覺得
如果你覺得後面看好
就是不會再惡化的話
那麼現在就是底
因為現在的估值
確實是
怎麼說呢
跟去年4月份是一樣
然後說一下
在不同情況下
FOMC的影響
當然
上週的
這個會議計要出來的FATDOT
其實
相對來說比較
比較硬派一點
其實硬派的原因更多的是因為
JPOW出來講
沒有特別去關注失業的情況
然後同時的話
他提到了就是
那個政治原因
就伊朗這些問題的
可能帶來的不決定性
有一點意外的是
只有一個designant
就是一個人說
我要投票design
上次好像是2.83個
就說明
這個相當於是比較硬派的一個信號
因為
大家其實都是傾向於觀望
但是市場的定價呢
在現在的市場
就是對於
在伊朗的
這個戰爭的問題的情況下
現在市場定價
其實我覺得
對於利率是偏於
偏
過多的考慮了通脹
這個也是根據這個
我們後面才會說到
我們在做
不要說投資
在想去抄底的時候
應該去怎麼做
過多的定價的通脹是因為
包括我們看到10年期利率
4.3以上的
然後短期利率
現在全部在往上跑
甚至
有很多投行
現在認為今年可能不降息
杰比摩卡爾還是最最好笑
這邊沒有杰比摩卡爾
杰比摩卡爾還是最好笑
甚至覺得不但NO CUT
有可能還會覺得
還會升息
結果我覺得這個可能性不上達
因為每家投行分期很大
有一些投行
就相對來說
覺得會更加強一點
覺得今年不太會降息
我覺得不太會降息
和市場開始有的時候
定價會升息是兩回事
就不太
不太會降息
是我對於通脹
會不會導致
經濟衰退有一個分析
但是升息
是沒有任何過往的
是非常非常難
我們回頭可以看一下90年的
當時的海玩危機
低潮玩危機
90年低潮玩危機的時候
其實美聯儲基本把利息
維持在一個水平的家
水平的位置沒有動
但是之前它是有降息的空間的
所以在發生危機之前
它先降了一次息
然後把利息維持的活動
90年把油價搞上去
搞了挺長時間
因為三萬五把油警都燒掉了
我們是覺得
我是覺得在今年可能9月份的時候
現在為什麼本質上
我一直不覺得有通脹
或者我覺得通脹的問題
並不那麼嚴重
或者美聯儲其實在通脹
和增長兩個選擇的時候
永遠就經過這麼多年
它的屁股永遠是坐在增長這一邊
所以經濟增長這一邊
所以從這個來說的話
我們會在今年可能9月份
可能夜市三季多的時候
根據前面的這個Tariff的這些影響
全部消退以後
我們會在這個時候看到
失業率可能會在4.6以上
失業率開始上升到4.6以上以後
那麼對於聯儲的態度
可能會更加傾向於各派
哪怕當時的油價比較高
哪怕Helland PCE比較高
那我覺得就是說
不太會有深吸的可能
然後這個經濟增長才是本質
因為你的通脹並不是一個
這個2022年
比方說額外危機之後
發生的通脹是不一樣的
它的本質不是supply constraint
特別不是service supply constraint
就不是那個我們叫做工資螺旋上升
不是勞工不足供應不足
然後當時發了很多的錢
印了很長時間的錢
然後導致通脹要一下子這樣的爆發
真的不是
這是一次性的event
一次性的戰爭導致的能源價格的上升
所以它對於整體可持續的
比較可持續通脹影響不是很大的
它更大的
我覺得是反向的到時候會影響增長
這個影響就是可能會更加負面
所以我是感覺得
市場到時候的交易會在這樣的一個方向
就是如果說WarsCase發生的話
我們說ifWarsCase發生
它是會先有個all your panic
就是我們這次講的all your crisis panic
就是大家怕油價上升
然後怕inflation上升
然後把利率和資本市場
把利率和風險市場全部打下去
就duration的債
就是股債雙跌
現在就是股債雙跌
上周就是股債雙跌
然後股債雙跌之後
會進入一個recession phase
就是大家會擔心增長不及百分之二
會擔心美國這個衰退
即使那個時候油價還是很高
但是還是會擔心衰退
所以但最後會有可能的
因為各方面原因
就是我覺得美國的會有政策
一個流動性其實今年並不差
雖然油價上升
但是financial conditions next其實並不差
第二就是會有一部分的退稅
就是三四季度的這個退稅會有影響
所以我覺得最後大家會覺得
recession phase沒有那麼嚴重
即使真的發生了兩說降到20%以內的recession
在某些sector上面
在那個網絡半導體
我覺得就是第二個capitulate
就是第二個投降
就是大家會投降於token的需求是每年數倍的增長
然後token需求是真實的user case會出來
然後半導體沒有問題
所以這個會第二次capitulate
那個時候很多的acquity會瘋漲
一定會漲過一定會漲過前高
這個我覺得毫無疑問
你一定會漲過前高
所以但是經過這個三個face的過程
其實投資最好的是在第二個face的時候去買國債
就是你如果敢認為這個市場到底了
或者認為這個石油危機到底了
石油危機的影響就好像我們剛剛第二個配置講的
石油危機的影響不是以自行解鎖的
它對於經濟增長的影響
已經就今天哪怕結束
它今天不會馬上結束
就這個月底馬上結束
它對0.3GDP以下還是會發生
因為它抹一貼的它已經漲上去了
然後後面還會有一些risk premium
它不太會馬上就馬上就下來
所以即使如此
我們會面臨一個更加嚴峻的在美國
會面臨一個更加嚴峻的增長的預期
在全球會面臨一個double嚴峻的增長預期
雙倍增長預期
你看看這些石油運到哪裡去
就是整個海峽的石油運到哪裡去
中國是很大的一個比率
然後東亞是很大的比率
中國和東亞都很大
然後美國運一些
但是美國本身是有出口過
然後你可以這樣想
就是美國已經控制了委內瑞拉的石油
然後北美的石油本身可以自己自作
在這個危機裡面出口
四個面臨桶的美國
如果能夠保持
有一個概念是那個
PTSL那幫人說的
就是叫長期戰爭
包括額外戰爭就是一個長期戰爭
就是美國如果能夠保持
不影響它國內反戰情緒
油價上升肯定會反戰
如果海峽是通常的
它可以持續的一直給你打
只要不死人
國內就沒有餘興反彈
然後我就可以持續戰爭
所以這個是美國在
AIS在提出一個新的戰爭的模式
叫持續戰爭
如果它能夠維持持續戰爭
在那裏製造
一直製造矛盾
其實它作為在石油方面
它和中東國家是競爭對手
它也是出口過
那可以多買點美國的使用
所以對它的影響反而都沒有那麼大
那我說它了
就對於全球這個資本市場影響
可能會比
肯定會對比比美國更加嚴重
因為你最近也看
那個全世界的貨幣
對吧
美元是走的最堅定
它打仗不影響它
它的貨幣走的非常堅定
美元是走的很堅定
就是我國頭講
就是美國還是會有衰退的影響
雖然它影響最小
但是它還是會衰退的影響
衰退的影響下面
利率就小往下跑
我們年初其實就覺得利率是今年一個
非常容易吹的
容易交易的一個標的
所以當如果在那個市場在底部
不敢買的時候
你先想想你敢不敢買債
你敢不敢買sorption
敢不敢買tlt的library 3倍的tlt
敢不敢去買那個東西
如果你這個東西不敢買
那股票你也不敢買
就是股票你還得就是風險資產
你最後還得去看它
經濟增長影響第二波的這個中間
沒過來
就是第二波的我們叫做recession fair
如果最壞情況發生
recession fair或者是經濟
經濟變差的影響還沒過來
但是如果是當然了
這個是昨天債也是利率也會下來
就是如果說你們覺得馬上
這個問題要解決
和whats case可能會不太一樣
馬上要解決
你可以直接去買股票
但是如果你覺得後面還是會有
我們叫做有一個最大痛的時機
maxman pain
最大痛的時機是在
大家認為這個戰爭可能會
維持一個更長的時間
我也不知道打到那天
然後好像沒頭了一樣
川普講的話
一話這樣一話
也沒有也沒有健康把這個
這個傳給讓你過去
然後伊朗可能談到他不錯
他說談好了
然後他還去攻擊這個傳
到底怎麼回事
大家開始這樣質疑的時候
然後你們覺得到底了
到底的時候
你覺得到底是去買戰
我覺得4.5以上是很難
那個經濟性也沒有完全不支持這個東西
然後最後說一下倉穩
市場的頭寸和倉穩
市場頭寸是前一段時間
我們一直覺得
從三個角度
第一個是Gama
就是跌的時候
投降在賣
去年跌的時候投降在賣
所以維持了價錢
現在跌的時候投降在賣
然後Gama
第二個是盤口流動性
S&P liquidity
Top of the order
現在在4.1個面臨
然後以前在13個面臨
這個意思就是現在大概三分之一
我跌的時候跌得更兇
因為盤口沒人掛單了
然後第三個很重要的就是CTA
CTA是或者我們叫Systematic Position
叫做策略性策略
策略性倉位
然後根據市場波動就自動的買入
賣出沒有主觀盤單
他還不管說固執著這東西
策略性倉位
我們認為Position很危險
我記得是春節左右吧
春節後
春節前後
那一個月
就是到上週再上週
賣了80個筆臉
這裡沒有寫
這裡是過去一個月
賣了大概80個筆臉的這個倉位
然後上一週
一週大概賣了78個筆臉
再上週也是賣了挺多的
所以上一週
其實你看這市場下跌
有很多的動力
不光是政治的動力
其實倉位的賣出
然後Negative Gamma
Gamma
抓到的時候
它就會賣更多
然後都是一起聯繫
一起影響這個市場
我們講的預期
下一週賣47個筆臉
這是Global F6
就是全球的
預期
美國大概在這中間的一半吧
你就如果說到Global CTA的話
那就美國在這個中間大概在一半
全球賣47個是Flatcase
就是它如果持平
它還會去賣
所以在這個很小的圖上
右下角很小的圖上
就是這一段
它會繼續去賣出
但是在這個47個筆臉賣完以後
下一個月
我們整體來說
下一個月的話
在Flatcase大概是賣50到60個筆臉
那就拋掉下一個星期
後面如果市場持平
它就不賣了
但是你想市場如果上漲
下個星期
我怎麼說
我就下個星期
它可能賣30個筆臉300億
但下個月
就是重新的開始往後看一個月
如果上漲的話
上漲一個Standard Division
它是要買回來137個筆臉
所以就好像這個圖
這個圖畫是畫到後面一點以後
就是在你可能會看到
不管漲跌
接下來都是要賣出一部分
但是明顯往下的彈性
明顯往下的彈性
跟往上彈性變得不平均
這個就好像我們在2月份的時候
看到反向的不平均一樣
就是往上它彈不動了
但是往下的Standard Division會賣很多的
這個是2月份的狀態
但是在現在狀態是
我覺得市場是相反的
就是它可以往上買很多
所以我們說的就是
怎麼說呢
就是現在賣出
在這一周肯定是完全沒有完全結束
但是往上的動能在很大程度上在累積
這個最後就取決於
我們說的伊朗的談判會怎麼樣
會不會談好
或者能不能沒有談好
然後給你一個機會去去買一把
我覺得這個概率也挺大的
就是因為政治上我不太好做判斷
然後如果
因為我一開始就說
這個船是創和內達尼亞湖和伊朗的這幫神棍們
大家一起在開的
他們是有發動機的
那我只能說市場上的風向在怎麼吹
市場上的風向現在肯定是吹的往下面再吹
就是往空頭吹
但是這個壓力在累積
給你看後面的這個篡位的狀態
就是壓力現在在累積
這邊沒有寫下來的是大概137個別鏈的upside
就是下一個月可以會買路
路我是往上漲會買路
所以你會很有可能是真的情況轉好
那會看到一個反向的風向
我們生活以待吧
我覺得這一周有兩個比較重要的數據
兩個比較重要的那個看法
就是一個我覺得是兩個沒有投降
就是現在市場並沒有停下
伊朗會油價會一直很高
伊朗危機會維持下去
它斷流的規模是歷史上
就是石油危機裡面最嚴重
然後這個沒有停下
第二個呢市場沒有定下token的需求
這個兩個觀點是衝突的
但是在時間上它是不衝突的
就是伊朗的問題如果要爆發
它會爆發它前面
但是token的需求
你是需要時間不停的去印證它的
你看到anthropic open air的這個這個這個
調用量
然後每一個月在瘋狂上升
到一個時點
然後其他的agent調量也很大
到一個時點開始會capitulate
會投降好吧
我們今天先要不講到
by the way這個是這個global cta的這個差跡
你可以看到global cta其實已經
已經賣空的量超過了
當時在4月份的時候
美國還沒有美國現在沒有
s&p還沒有跌到那個位置
但是已經賣空的量超過
當時4月份賣空的量
但s&p的估值
因為很多大公司的盈利
實際增長了很多
s&p很多大公司的估值
包括微軟包括大部分的mega3
其實除了5個
其實都已經回到了去年這個
就是去年4月份那個那個底部那位置
所以我說估值上其實已經到底了
但是賣空的量上了
其實這個星期
你這個netweek是給中國中部線
是這個星期
其實還是有繼續賣空的動力
我們看看有什麼問題
我們給QNN一下吧